Stories like this are the reason why I think
women should think twice about having children,
because children are not, are not given, like,
the respect that they deserve in the world.
People don't. Look,
the society in general is, like,
really annoyed at kids, like,
but he thinks it's really funny to just, like,
not accept kids and laugh at how stupid kids are,
how annoying kids are. And it's kind of like the sentiment,
like, when you go out in public with children,
they are looked at like, so annoying.
You are looked at like, oh,
my god, somebody brought kids.
Fucking gray. And it's like,
just really, like.
I mean, even the grocery store you get looks like,
why are there fucking kids here?
Like, you're supposed to have children.
But then children aren't really allowed to exist anywhere or be kids.
And, like, they.
It's a learning process. They have to learn how to behave in public by
kind of being shitty in public sometimes.
And it's our job as a community,
as a society, and as their moms to, like,
do that, but it's not really welcome.
People are going way too far with the hate they have for kids,
which makes it really fucking hard to be a mom,
and it makes you feel really unsafe for your children.
I just think being a kid is hard,
and being a mom of those kids is also really hard.